[Music]
do
you
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
hi welcome to the table my name
is don jacobs and we are so thrilled
that you're here
um so it has been a crazy week
uh here in texas so those of you who are
have been in texas
you know exactly what i'm talking about
i don't have to explain that for those
of you i do because i know there's a few
of you who do pay attention to who are
outside the state we have had some
very extreme cold um that is very
not common for the state of texas it's
working to
um antarctica almost
um it has been crazy cold um
here and it started off at least for me
it started off one of those things where
i was like oh my gosh it's snow i've not
seen snow
in ages and snow when it first falls is
beautiful i mean it's absolutely
beautiful if you go on a walk in it's
very calming
it's quiet it's just it's an amazing
thing it's just like things are perfect
and things changed for quite a number
of us so i know that this week has been
super challenging with many of us
without power um
some of us without water uh me
personally i have this is my first time
been home
i've been in my home for about an hour
because just it just was this was not a
good place for you to be home
um and i know that many of you guys have
probably either have been displaced or
if you stayed home you
it was just really difficult um so
there's a couple of things
um one hopefully if you could look back
back on this week and think of something
that was really good
um something positive because i know
i've met i've seen some of you guys on
social media
i've seen pictures of you guys um either
building snowmen
or playing with snowballs or doing snow
angels or
doing things with the family and they
have been really cool
um and because i had the opportunity of
seeing some of this on social media from
you guys
um it'd be really cool to be able to
share that with just
our table community so if you wouldn't
mind maybe if you feel so inclined
uh posting some of those amazing
pictures that you
um also share on social media or
whatever you'd like
um down in the notes um below uh we
would love to be able to
to see some of those positive moments
because we need to try to take as many
positive uh moments at this
last week we possibly can um but
um also if you are one of those folks
who because of the extreme
cold um maybe you're still kind of
without power maybe you're still in a
situation where you can't be home
um water is kind of an issue
didn't think that was going to have to
be an issue but until i had to
experience it myself either
but we would also like to know that as
well so
brett's email is going to be listed
below as well
so just send send uh send us a message
we'd like to know see what
ways that we can possibly help and
support you um in that
and so we can make sure that your needs
are being met
uh one quick announcement is about the
state of the tables happening
one week um from today after this
um after our normal service uh so this
is something we do about twice a year
uh you can think about kind of like a
family meeting
but for church and so this is something
that you can hear about like the latest
on everything from leadership
transitionings that are happening
um new initiatives and focus for the
year potential dates for reopening
because that's important to know
and then of course if that any of that
stuff is important to you
please join us um anyone who cares about
the table
is welcome to participate so we'd love
to see
that so again this it's going to be
online um it's going to be at 7 excuse
me
6 15 to about 7 15. one week from today
brett will be emailing out a link for
google meets and so if you're not on
the email list make sure you also
comment below
so we can make sure we get you at it i'm
going to transition to us into prayer
um i was it's been
as i mentioned before it has been a
nutty week
um i it's been weird because i haven't
been able to even personally check in
with other people because i haven't been
in a space
to be able to where my own personal
world is just rock because of all this
so it's kind of weird to be in a
position
where i can't turn around and try to
give to other people
because i'm usually a person that can
turn around and help and support and
care and pray for and at least be
enlisting here
for folks and so i didn't realize until
i got home how much
pressure and stress i personally have
been under this last week
and i'm thankful for
uh so thankful that i can tune into
this and plug into y'all and
hear from this community and be able to
just reconnect um with people who are
important to me
um with um being able to
understand that i god is in control of
all this
i don't have to be and so
with that i just want to listen to
prayer
lord thank you so much um
thank you that you are in control
thank you that you are a person and
a god that loves us um
even in the midst of all of this crazy
stuff that has gone on
um i pray lord that
we've been with the week that we've had
um that many of us have had that we can
just
um tune into you specifically
in this moment open up our hearts
open up our minds help us to
hear exactly what you need um
what what you need to share with us
today i pray you just speak through
brett's words tonight i pray you speak
through the music
help us just to connect and connect with
you
in christ now pray amen
hey guys um good to see you
and it's so funny that dawn was just
talking about how this week
sorry i always forget okay
it's funny how don was just talking
about how this week he was
you know dealing with so much on a
personal level that it was so difficult
to even be able to attempt to turn
his eyes outward and reach out towards
others
um that's actually the thoughts that i
was writing down
thinking through the set tonight
brett is going to be touching on like
the theme of shame and
just kind of how our junk our sin our
mistakes
um can lead us down that path of shame
and guilt and um what we do with that
um can be like we have the option
to um respond to those feelings
with self-compassion um
and believing that jesus is able to
transform us
is able to redeem us as able to make
something beautiful out of our mess
and um one thing i was reflecting on
as i was thinking about that theme that
he was going to talk about
was um and you'll hear this
in the songs is just we have an
opportunity i have an opportunity to
just kind of name and be honest
about my mistakes and the areas where i
fail
just kind of name that human frailty
and then respond the way that christ
responds to me
um and i believe that is with compassion
i believe that is with transformation um
where his forgiveness is so readily
available and
what he's um calling us to constantly
is being pulled upward and outward
instead of
inward and downward and my tendency is
in and down
like i make a mistake i immediately feel
tons of shame and guilt
and bury myself in it but when i'm
believing
those themes of redemption that the
gospel offers
i am able to not only have compassion
for myself but to look outward and help
others and serve others and realize
that this life is much more than about
me and my mess
um and that there's people around me
that
have needs and um and and my
shortcomings even connect me to those
people around me
um rather than hoping that i always am
going to get it right
every single time and then that almost
being a separation
um from real life and from me and
and you know my friends and family and
the people that god puts in my path
so anyway those are just some of the
thoughts that i've had stirring
um as i was preparing for tonight and
um like i said there's lyrics that
you'll hear that are kind of
backing up that thought of of starting
with honesty
um and naming our human condition and
then
moving into a position of belief that um
jesus is redeeming us and turning it
into something beautiful
and also pulling us outside of ourselves
where we are able to
serve and love and give of who we are to
others
so i just invite you guys into that
space
with us tonight and we're going to get
[Music]
started
will your grace
out
if i let you
down
cause all i
know is i am a sinner if it's not one
thing
it's another i'm caught up
in words
you are a savior and you take brokenness
aside
and make
you call me
[Music]
is how to cry
cause i am a sinner it's not a one thing
it's another i'm caught up in
words in lies
when you are a savior and you take
[Music]
brokenness
you make it beautiful
[Music]
you made it beautiful
you make it beautiful
cause i am a sinner if it's not one
thing
it's another i'm caught
[Music]
you take brokenness aside and make it
brokenness aside and make it beautiful
beautiful lord you make it
beautiful beautiful
lord you make
[Music]
beautiful
worthy of all the praise we could ever
bring
worthy of every breath we could ever
breathe
jesus the name above every other name
jesus
worthy of every breath we could ever
breathe
there is no one like you
there is none beside you
open up my eyes in
one and show me
who you are and fill me
with your heart and lead me
in your love to those around me
[Music]
worthy of every song we could ever see
worthy of all the praise we could ever
bring
worthy of every breath that we could
ever breathe
and holy there is no one like you
there is none beside you
[Music]
around me
it is a firm foundation
and i will put my
trust in you
i will never
[Applause]
[Music]
it is a firm boundary
and i will not
and holy there is no one like you
there is none beside you
open up my eyes in
wonder and show me
who you are
around me
[Music]
we believe in
nothing but
[Music]
me
foreign
[Music]
is
this is all my
open peace
[Music]
[Applause]
makes me white
[Music]
nothing but the blood of
jesus
[Music]
thank you so much god for a love that
goes beyond
all my mistakes all my failures my
shortcomings
that loves me just as i am
and that calls me forward
thank you god that even
when i'm feeling that conviction where i
know i need to
change that your love is always
about freedom it's always calling me
towards being
more free in who you made me to be god
thank you that your love lacks all
shame
[Music]
that there is no condemnation
for us who believe
because you are love
in your nature in your being in the core
of who you
are and how you created this world to
function
there is at the center of it
love
god that is the gospel that i want us to
so badly take into our life
[Music]
that's the message that i want us to
sink our roots down
into and live from
a love that knows no shame
but is transformed
[Music]
god may we take that same love and share
it with this world around us
would we be a light in darkness would we
be hope
in the midst of hopelessness would we be
transformation
and change where there is brokenness and
pain
would you be our redemption would you be
the voice in the wilderness
calling us forward calling us
into this world
god would your love show us where we are
at home
and would we ground ourselves in it
thank you that you are my home you are
my beginning
thank you guys thanks for entering into
the moment with us
brett it's all yours
thank you maggie and mindy um well
everyone
good evening grace and peace
welcome to the table and uh as don
mentioned
well multiple things but um one
obviously
what a week i'm glad you all are here
you've made it and uh yeah i'm really
proud of how our community
came together i know there are a lot of
texts and things flying around and
people communicating and making sure
everyone's taken care of
um and that is that's that's beautiful
so makes me
proud and happy as a as a pastor of this
community
um and also i know he mentioned the uh
the state of the table
meeting next week and um
you know that is that something only
happens twice a year and
it's um basically that meaning it's
basically an expression of our values
for being um both communal and
vulnerable um in other words like open
and honest
you know so really it's kind of a time
for us to pull back the curtain so to
speak and be just really upfront with
everyone
on um kind of you know all the things
like everything from vision
for the year to um you know finances
um and you know leadership transitions
just and everything in between so
um anyway if you are if you care about
the table uh
as a local church expression then um i
encourage you to join us next week
so all right we are beginning a new
series
uh titled lent from repentance to
renewal and i know the season of lent is
it's not something that's you know
familiar to everyone so here's a little
background
in the ancient church easter was
traditionally a day
where you would baptize um new believers
so
people who had you know newly put their
trust in christ
and uh and since that was such a
significant moment it was normally
preceded
by 40 days of spiritual preparation
uh with a special focus on fasting and
prayer
uh now you ask why 40 so glad you asked
so
40 is the significant number in the
bible for example the children of israel
after their exodus from egypt they
wandered for 40 years in the desert
before entering the promised land
and then later jesus as you may recall
spent 40 days
fasting and praying um in the
desert where he ultimately you know
encountered the famous temptations of
worldly success and power from the devil
at that moment um so that was just prior
to his ministry so
you know this number 40 this this and
this idea of 40 days it sort of took
hold
uh in the christian imagination and thus
over time
the idea of lent developed into a
broader season of preparation
not just for new christians but but
eventually for the entire church
so uh in short lent it's really um it's
the season in the church calendar
that leads specifically up to good
friday that of course is the day of
jesus crucifixion and then a few days
later easter
so uh as you can probably tell from what
i just named
that means lent is about much more than
simply
giving things up uh like chocolate or
red wine or meat
it's really about spiritual preparation
and that preparation can happen both by
fasting something
um you know letting something go that
your your flesh kind of craves like
chocolate or meat or you know one meal a
day or something
or by tanki taking something up so you
could um
engage a new spiritual discipline or
practice that's also
you know something people do at length
so for example maybe you're someone
and you've never really you know prayed
very consistently
uh you know if that's the case then
perhaps your lenten practice would be to
i don't know pray the lord's prayer um
every morning and evening you know in
the days leading up to good friday
um so that would be uh you know a
positive thing you could engage
so all that to say lent it's it's less
about like
feeling bad it's not really the point of
lineage just to feel real bad
or to count all your sins every day
rather it's a season of spiritual
training
and preparation as we move towards
easter
so if you haven't already i want to
encourage you to be thinking today
of what you would might want to you know
let go of
too fast um or what you might want to
take up
uh you know a new spiritual practice to
engage in the season of
lent so with that in mind uh the title
of my message
this first sunday of lent is from
self-rejection
to self-compassion from self-rejection
to self-compassion our primary text is
going to be psalm
25 um verses 1 through 10
and our very own caitlyn and brandon
randall are going to
go ahead and read our scripture this
evening
so let's go ahead and do that
let's go ahead
psalm 25 1-10
in you lord my god i put my trust
i trust in you do not let me be put to
shame
nor let my enemies triumph over me
no one who hopes in you will ever be put
to shame
but shame will come on those who are
treacherous without cause
show me your ways lord teach me your
paths
guide me in your truth and teach me for
you
our god my savior and my hope
is in you all day long remember lord
your great mercy and love for they are
from
of old do not remember the sins of my
youth
and my rebellious ways according to your
love
remember me for you lord are good
good and upright is the lord therefore
he instructs sinners in his ways
he guides the humble in what is right
and teaches them his way
all the ways of the lord are loving and
faithful towards those who keep
the demands of his covenant
beautiful i love when people we have
like folks that i haven't seen in a
while
um can do readings and things like that
so thank you so much brandon and caitlin
uh so all right so here's my big idea
for tonight and um it honestly it may
sound a little strange because we tend
to think
of guilt as a very bad thing but as
you'll see
i want us to take kind of a fresh look
at that so so here's the big idea
at its best guilt leads me
to a place of humility and
self-compassion
not shame and self-rejection that's a
big idea at its best skill leads me to a
place of humility
and self-compassion not shame and
self-rejection
so i i think understandably um
brand christianity kind of has this
reputation
in our culture for uh a heavy
dose of guilt uh if you've seen the
movie spanglish
came out a number of years ago uh you
may recall the scene where
john klasky he's the character played by
adam sandler
he just had this like big argument with
his housekeeper
flor fleur
about the way too large amount of money
that he paid her daughter
christina for finding sand smoothed
glass on the beach
and the blob it was big enough that
floor kind of feels like she probably
needs to just quit
uh her job since the relationship just
the dynamic just feels strange now
because she's like called out her boss
you know
and so she says uh i quit um
but both john and the daughter for
various reasons they they really don't
want her to quit
so john says to flora he says
uh you can't quit the job even if you
wanted to
and you know why and
florida she's like very confused she's
like um
no and john says yes you do
you know and she says
why because john says
if you do christina will blame
herself for costing you the job
and that guilt i don't know if you know
about guilt and then christina jumps in
with this line
guilt oh we know we're catholics
we know so that movie that's like that
line has never that scene has never left
me
uh i mean obviously it's kind of picking
on catholic christians
um but truth be told that's a charge
brought against
many different wings of uh of
christendom
this idea that it just layers the guilt
on thick and as i named earlier you know
we're now in the season of lent
which as it's popularly understood is
basically the season of guilt
right if christmas is the season of
cheer
lent is the season of guilt
so the broader culture has really
reacted
quite strongly against this and you can
think of it like a pendulum
christianity had the guilt pendulum
way to one side but then beginning in
the 1960s
60s you can see the cultural movers and
shakers the artists and poets and
philosophers and writers in there
they're kind of leaving the christianity
thing behind
and they're swinging the pendulum wildly
the other
way and and the idea was basically that
we're shaking
off all that guilt stuff
all that psychological oppression and
heaviness
in fact even today it's it's not
uncommon for folks who have left
christianity behind uh enjoined perhaps
you know the atheist kind of agnostic
crowd or
or more likely the the spiritual but not
religious
um kind of contingent um what they'll
often say
almost having like a testimony so to
speak is something like this
um it feels so good
to be rid of all that guilt
god was like this oppressive watcher
just hovering over me and my pastor and
my parent parents told me for years
god sees god sees everything you do and
he's keeping a list
and on the day of judgment you will have
to give account for everything
in fact not only for what you do but
even for what you
think i mean remember jesus teaching
even if a person lusts after someone in
their heart
they have committed adultery with them
so remember
god sees and
and you know there was something about
probably the intensity and the
repetition of something you know
messages along those lines
you know um people reacted to that so
understandably you know when you frame
guilt in that way
and you add in a few dashes of fear for
good measure
uh it's it's pretty understandable why
many folks are in reaction
to to that in the culture in fact just a
few months ago i met with someone for
a coffee and they're pretty new to the
table they've just been visiting us
for a few months kind of online here and
there just kind of dipping their toe in
the pool so to speak and uh and so i i
asked him like okay so
you know share your story a little bit
with me and it was really um remarkable
because he was raised in a very strict
fundamentalist christian
household like it was borderline kind of
cult-like in the sense that
their denomination their little little
sliver of christianity was the only one
going to heaven
and uh you know so not even most
christians were getting in
uh only their little tribe and uh but as
he shared he said they're really like
three things that that he found just
very
unbearable uh so a it was control
there was a sense of who your friends
were who you could date i mean
everything was just tightly controlled
um because they just didn't want you to
go outside the bounds of the church you
know into the scary world
um which kind of leads to the second one
it was fear
so danger lurked everywhere temptation
lurked everywhere bad people bacon
people were all around you
the devil's trying to get you so watch
out and he said for him
it became this kind of deep-seated
almost paranoia about
the world and then third and finally the
guilt
since god was like this all-seeing
bureaucrat keeping scrupulous count of
your sins
you were constantly either fighting back
sin
or living with a deep sense of
guilt because you had failed
and and not just that you had failed
but really that you were a
failure and and that's the idea i want
to hone in on
tonight it's not just that you'd failed
but that you were a
failure can you hear the difference
between those two
like that's just a small shift in
language
and yet that shift is like the grand
canyon
and so my question is what's behind
that difference i think at least in
in the context i'm familiar with like
christianity and church
i believe it's often the image of god
operating behind the scenes so to speak
in other words what kind of a parent is
god
is god like a loving father a loving
mother
or is god more like a verbally
emotionally
even physically abusive parent
and think of it like how we relate to
our kids
so if our kid messes up uh not if
when when our kid messes up and for the
sake of argument let's just say in this
example let's say it's it's
like a big deal whatever they just did
it was like pretty messed up
it was wrong and so as a parent in that
moment
do you say i'm not surprised
you're such a failure your behavior
is so unacceptable i'm not even sure i
can allow you to remain
in the family it's not just what you did
that's embarrassing
you are an embarrassment
it is that what we say no
like that's called bad parenting that's
verbally abusive parenting what
what do we say at our best
we say something along these lines okay
look
you're right what you did was wrong and
extremely hurtful not only to that other
person
but even to you but look at me
that's not who you are
i know you the real you the deeper you
and i know you are called to better than
that
i know you can do better and so i want
you to apologize to them
i want you to own your crap and then you
know what
let's move forward and hey
i love you nothing can ever change that
you know it that's what i would say to
my kids you know it
and they say yeah i know it
now what's the difference between those
two parenting moments
um brene brown she's uh the famous
shame researcher that's really kind of
burst on the scene in the last like
decade or so
and she has drawn what i believe is a
very very helpful distinction
between guilt and shame
she said guilt is a focus on behavior
uh i did something bad shame
is a focus on the self i am
something bad in other words
guilt says i'm sorry i made a mistake
whereas shame says i'm sorry
i am a mistake
can you hear the difference there i mean
it's just one word made
versus am made a mistake am
a mistake it's just one word but it is
all the difference in the world and i
wonder
if in our culture's rush to swing the
pendulum
i wonder if in our culture's diagnosis
of the problem of christianity being
guilt i wonder if that
was actually a misdiagnosis
because here's the truth a pang of
conscience is not a bad
thing uh heck i mean depending on the
circumstances
even some very deep grief and
tears and a what have i done
guilt like that that's honestly bad in
fact
that that is an essential part of being
human
like when we mess up it is good
and right that an alarm goes off in our
head that says
nope that wasn't good
that's not right right that's that's
guilt and as jiminy cricket says and
always let your conscience be your guide
right i mean that's good advice and
and you know um i mean actually what the
medical label is for someone
who doesn't experience this who doesn't
have conscience who doesn't have that
guilt uh it's called being psychopathic
like you you literally you lack empathy
of any sort there's
there's no conscience and and actually
that's a
dangerous place to be and i don't think
like the even the broader culture
actually wants us to be
psychopaths you know but but you it's
easy to misread because it's like hey no
more guilt
no more guilt that's actually kind of a
recipe for hell on earth
so uh so what have people been reacting
to
in the church i don't think it was the
guilt
uh what was it it was shame
that i think that's what we in the
church
and as a pastor i'll just speak on
behalf of like clergy
that at our worst we have we've shifted
not
not kind of away from guilt you did
something wrong and we've shifted over
to shame
you in your being in your essence
you are wrong you are a mistake
like that that shift again it may sound
small that that's a shift that that can
just wreak profound damage in people
and this is why i find um psalm chapter
so beautiful because you can hear the
writer
walking this tightrope of acknowledging
their own messed upness
without slipping into shame
verse 7 of psalm 25 do not remember
the sins of my youth and my rebellious
ways in other words lord i have done
some very stupid and downright terrible
things
yes today and this week and this month
in this year
but especially lord when i was young
and dumb especially when i was
insecure and hormonal and impulsive and
stupid
you see that's do not remember right
that that's saying
that's forgiveness lord forgive them do
not remember the sins of my youth in my
rebellious
ways but then the writer continues
according to
your love remember me
according to your love remember me
for you lord are
good this comes right back to the type
of parent goddess
god is like a good mother
a good father who in spite of
all our stupidity and rebelliousness
and ego when god looks at
us when when he looks at you
when god recalls to mind
who you have been and who you are
it is always from a place a posture
of love according to your love
remember me for you lord are
good and skipping down to verse 9
he guides the humble in what is right
and teaches them his way this is why i
said my big idea for tonight was that at
its best
guilt leads me to a place of humility
and self-compassion not shame and
self-rejection
and that's the trick right normally we
so quickly slide
from a place of guilt from the paying of
conscience like oh i messed up
to a place of self loathing
and self-rejection that is shame
but instead we need to begin to slide
in a different direction the language i
used in my big idea was
the place of humility and
self-compassion
and i i got the language of humility of
course from psalm 25 there was in verse
nine
um but the language of self-compassion
that i received from dr kristen neff
she teaches psychology at the university
of texas
and one of her areas of research is on
the differences
between self-esteem and self-compassion
i'm really curious about how this
language of self-compassion
struck you i don't know if it sounds
kind of self-indulgent
you know like especially all you texas
people y'all can be tough
um so i don't know i'm kind of curious
um
and that got me to thinking like is that
kind of narcissist
narcissistic like oh you know i'm just i
just have so much compassion for myself
all the time you know
like oh is there something weird in that
um so i started doing a little research
little digging
and i didn't realize that the
self-esteem movement
has fallen on hard times have y'all
heard about this i mean i was like all
the rage when i was growing up in like
elementary school it was like all about
self-esteem
uh and it's apparently it's like very
much
kind of out of favor now um not because
having a high sense of self-worth or
self-esteem is intrinsically
bad um the problem researchers
discovered
is how you get it and often the way
self-esteem was framed to young children
was that you have value because you are
not like other people
you you are you are above average
in every era you are just great in
everything you do right because they
were trying to give kids self-esteem
um but what it kind of led to was kids
who grew up well they had high
self-esteem but they were also
um quite narcissistic uh because it was
dependent on them
feeling better than other people um but
this
is where neff points out this that
self-esteem and self-compassion
really part ways you see self-compassion
is not about us quietly thinking
that well we're better than other people
uh
no in fact it's it's also it's not even
refusing to feel guilty or bad
that's not what self-compassion is
instead it is about learning to relate
to ourselves
as we would a good friend
that is like with some kindness honesty
but kindness i mean like for example
could you tell a good friend
that what they just did was wrong and
hurtful
sure i mean goodness i hope so or else
you aren't a very good friend
could you tell them you have some
outstanding strengths
and some striking weaknesses again
yes i hope so but if they messed up
would you shame them
would you tell them that they're
worthless and that you loathe them
no and yet what do we do to ourselves
we will be compassionate to everyone in
the world
except who us
it's that voice in the head it is brutal
like more than anyone else in the world
we shame
ourselves and that's why
we need to be oh so careful that we
begin to
see ourselves as god sees
remember the psalmist according to your
love
remember me so when we feel guilt let it
lead us to a place of repentance
humility and self-compassion not
shame not self-loathing
and not self-rejection we've got
to we've got to walk that tightrope and
so just conclude
we don't need to run from guilt again
a paying of conscience is not the worst
thing in the world
uh in fact it can be god's grace so
instead
let this season of lent let this season
of self-examination a fasting
of spiritual discipline this season of
the cross
let it i mean i just i hope it leads you
and i
to a place of deep humility
and self-compassion let me pray for you
lord jesus i thank you
i thank you for this season of
preparation that we're being invited
into
and
and i i suspect there's a lot of folks
who have
been listening to these words and
they've done a lot of
sliding from guilt into
shame from a pain of conscience into
shame
and i i pray that
you would set them free that you would
do a deep work in their hearts
where they could find this this way to
um
god where we can be convicted where we
can be humbled
and yet not start
to um just load ourselves
so i pray for that um for your spirit
spirit of freedom over people
god do a deep work heal us restore us
make us more like you in the powerful
name of jesus i pray
amen
we're just going to close with this last
song um
kind of reorienting our focus away from
um those thoughts that are about whether
we
are measuring up or whether we are good
enough and thinking about how faithful
and good
god is to us at all times
i love you
oh your lord never fails me
[Music]
all my days i've been
held in your hand
from the moment that i wake up
until i lay my head
i will sing of the goodness of god
all my life you have been faithful
oh my life you have been so
so good
with every breath that i am
able i will sing
of the goodness of god
i love your voice
you have led me through the fire
in darkest nights you are close
like no other
i've known you as a father
i've known you as a friend
and i have lived in the goodness of
my god you have been faithful
oh my life you have been so
so good
[Music]
your goodness is running after it's
running after me
your goodness
[Music]
my life is down i surrender now
and give you everything
your goodness is running after it's
running
after me
[Music]
is
it's running after me
[Music]
oh
my life you have been faithful
all my life you have been so
so good
with every breath that i
made
i will sing of the goodness of god
i will sing of the goodness
of god
oh thank you everyone for joining us
tonight um
if you're in need of prayer or support
as i mentioned before please make sure
that you
just give us a comment below email read
we'll
be happy to try our best to kind of meet
your needs wherever you are also
if this is a message that just resonates
with you
here at the table your vision the vision
the values that we have
um if you wouldn't mind uh if you feel
so inclined to
also support us in the work that we do
there's a link that will be below where
you can also
give so you can do that there also you
can visit the
website at thetable.tx.org
and do so at either one of those places
and then just as we close i just want to
share this
benediction with you this comes from
numbers
but the lord bless you and keep you
may the lord let me his face shine on
you
and be gracious to you may the lord turn
his face towards you and give you
peace especially peace from this week
be blessed have a good week and we will
see you
next sunday
you